The world at night is beautiful.
But it also tells a story of energy poverty.
Almost a billion people live here in Europe...
...nearly everyone has access to electricity.
A billion people live here in this part of Africa...
...only half have access to electricity.
There is no question that reliable electricity...
...unlocks a better life for people.
With electricity, food can be kept from spoiling.
Vaccines can be kept at a safe temperature.
Lights at night let people read and do homework.
Electricity powers businesses and creates jobs.
The world would become a richer, healthier,...
...and more equitable place if everyone had reliable access to electricity.
Right now the most effective way to create this access...
...is to build traditional electric generating plants...
...that burn fossil fuels.
Electricity generation creates 25 percent...
...of planet warming greenhouse gas emissions.
What's needed are affordable ways to bring clean energy...
...to nearly a billion people...
...who deserve more access to electricity.
That's why I'm making investments in clean,...
...affordable, and reliable ways to generate electricity...
...and I'm encouraging others to do the same.